the thing i appreciate about a lot of
muslims
is uh i don't know if it maybe it's
because of your 21st century oppression
so you know about shaitaan huh oh yeah i
want to really appreciate you know the
sincerity that you have
for 300 years the church uh mold
dude i'm starting to think that the
devil's like kind of like a really
really sick comedian where he's always
trying to
over those two words for 2000 years the
church has taught that god and the
trinity are synonyms 16 and onwards
how do you remember
assalamu alaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the dean show we have another
exciting
show he's back again he's an actor
comedian he was also the script writer
for louder from crowder also helped to
write a i believe a theme song for
tommy robinson guess who's back here on
the dean show
our good friend owen benjamin go ahead
and subscribe right now hit that
notification bell
help us get our numbers back up did you
know that many years ago
the dean show when we started 2006 we
used to broadcast for many years on the
khalifa clothing channel
currently known as digital minbot so
we're trying to get our numbers back up
because the channel
at that time got closed then we started
the official d show channel we're trying
to get our numbers back
up to where they should be and that's
this number here 855 combined what we
currently have 442
we should be over a million 200
000 subscribers help us to get our
numbers
back to where they should be with that
small setback that we had many years ago
you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification
bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show and don't forget to support us
on our patreon page
what's up betty how are you man good how
are you good to see you
how you been i've been really good it's
uh
it's really hot here and as you can see
i'm i'm in my uh i'm in an
animal stall right now because uh it's
like 105
in idaho and uh this is the coolest
place i could find
did i uh hit all those points right
actor comedian
former script writer for uh crowder
route louder crowder
and did i hit all those right did i
leave anything out
uh yeah i mean i've been at this a long
time those are some interesting
credits i guess i've it's been quite a
quite a journey
my friend i started i started yeah we
could
i wanted to talk to you about comedy
today anyway so like the the
journey of it has been pretty
interesting um well i started as a
piano player and then i headquartered a
renaissance fair where i made fun of
people who threw tomatoes at me when i
was in high school
and then uh sam i did stand up comedy
for a bit
open for kevin hart before anyone knew
who he was in college and then
um sandler put me in some movies because
he saw me do stand up and then i did
leno and fallon and
all this other stuff and then you know i
was one of the leads of a sitcom in l.a
and then i was outspoken about
being against transgender children
because i thought it was insane
and so then my agent manager dropped me
and then you know as you're as you're
kind of leaving the beast
the next level is kind of grabby and the
next level was like the neocon type like
prager and crowder and all those people
i thought they were speaking more the
truth and then
when i started uh getting out of some of
those illusions
i i left you know same with tommy
robinson and all those guys and now i'm
just kind of doing my own thing and
um you know i do a lot of farming and i
do a live stream every day and we have
an
app and we're trying to really figure
out the best way to
keep comedy going and not having it be
so illusion based and political you know
we're going to touch upon a lot of
different things i really really enjoyed
talking to you last time we got
such a positive feedback a lot of the
bears you know they really enjoyed it
and i yeah so we just really connected
was a really
positive program we did i have a good
friend of mine he's also going to join
us his name is dr sabile dr bill
how are you no no stranger he's from
gaine peace the director of game peace
owen benjamin this is dr sebille he's
going to be joining us on this episode
of the dean show sweet all right i'll
thank you
so i wanted good good good to see you
you too i want to get right into this
you did a program not too long ago and
i'm going to show some clips
you you've been talking about uh we'll
talk about farming towards the end we
want to talk about
uh something that's precious to you to
us you know
uh the purpose purpose of life you know
talk about
you know many of the things you know uh
the moral decay of society we'll touch
upon that
you know a lot of the commonalities that
we have will talk about the beard
you thought you found that
but let me start off with this clip
there was an intervention not too long
ago
where there was an intervention what was
it called a trinity intervention
trinity intervention yeah yeah yeah so
now you brought up there was um
dr rachel patrick coffin dr michael
jones
and then uh a gentleman a person by the
name of milo
he organized this what how did that how
did that start off why what was
what was the whole uh pretext behind
setting this up why were they
because i've seen some of your videos
you were kind of questioning
the trinity yeah i mean and i'm friendly
with all these people i loved
you michael jones and dr brown and i i
didn't know uh
patrick coffin before the intervention
and then i know milo he's
he's a really interesting character you
know he's a real trickster but
i root for the guy and so this all came
about because
as a christian i i i was questioning
jesus being god and i know there's a
little heavy just for like a
conversation but like i don't think it's
really backed up in the bible personally
like i was always like who's he praying
to you know
and i was being very innocent about it
and i don't
i'm not mad at people who think that
like i'm used to having a lot of friends
and acquaintances
having different beliefs but you know my
thing is i might be wrong but i'm not
lying
that's always what i go with and that
allows me to
to live a life with a heart-based life
where i can make mistakes and
and keep going is because at the time i
believe it you know
and so i had all these questions about
um you know jesus doing the
the bidding of his father and how you
can be your own father and all these
like basic questions you know and i was
raised catholic and
and to get more into the bible i started
seeing it more as god and then jesus
being the
the representative on earth the logos
incarnate
and so they did this uh this like
intervention
and i thought it went pretty well
because
i don't know i took it with a grain of
sand you know but i i just like uh i
don't know why people care so much about
it
you know it seems like that dogma has
kind of made it like the center point
of so much of christianity these days
and there's so much in the bible that
uh is so interesting and so helpful
especially
in these tumultuous times that i don't
get why that's
the be all end all of so many churches
and so yeah that's what that's about
one thing that i i wouldn't i would have
i would have disagreed in the beginning
before you even
even got into the trinity
was the homestead you know the uh
civilization
is to be in the city you know what i
mean and this
and people trying to look down upon that
you know
who are not really keen to really like
you talk about
planting your own fruit trees you know
your son your sons
getting out there developing good work
ethic connecting with nature
you know what i mean uh growing your own
food right
away from gmos away you know nutrition
proper nutrition
and it's like uh people looking at uh i
think it was kind of uh
made to seem like okay the quote was uh
you know to to be
civilization is in the cities you know
yeah which is crazy to me and that's why
i think that the real disconnect with
people is a lot more
uh between rural and urban and basically
how much sovereignty and how much uh
responsibility have you taken upon
yourself and
it's really interesting that that to get
out of some of these spells
was a lot of it had to do with living a
more similar life like
like rural christianity or rural
islamic people would probably have a lot
more in common
than super urban uh members of even
their same religion sometimes because
you have a lot
your life is more similar you know i uh
when i used to
you know after the 9 11 spell i you know
blamed
i i was never like hardcore but i was
like you know
we gotta go to war you know we gotta we
gotta avenge
you know never forget all that stuff
like it you know it made sense to me at
the time and as that
spell faded and one of the reasons it
faded was uh
i got my own goats and i was attacked by
the media and i saw a lot of the same
patterns that they did to muslims
happened to me and and you know
uh being a self-sustaining guy with
goats
you know like mocking that and then some
of my friends were doing the same jokes
against me that i was doing against
muslims
which were more just like rural it's not
even it's a category here it's all very
interesting but like
i started being like oh no that's not
what that means and then i saw how the
media was
attacking me and trying to categorize me
as a political position
and not just who i am and i saw the same
pattern they were doing in muslims
and um i don't hold on to grudges or
spells the minute i see through it
even if it costs me a lot of social uh
points and and financial points you know
that was one of the disagreements i had
with a lot of the neocons is
that um you know islam isn't the enemy
you know it's like especially another
reason is
you know you can say mass migration is
you can say that
flooding a country with a lot of people
from another country to keep this
this debt-based nonsense global machine
going
sure but i noticed a very tricky thing
they were doing they kept talking about
muslim immigrants but yet in america
you'd say mexicans not christians you
know like
most mexicans are catholic or christian
but you wouldn't categorize them as that
you'd say mexicans so it's interesting
how you have tribe and religion these
two categories
and another thing that that ingratiated
me to islamic culture is
one up a very close friend who's one of
the wise people i know and he's
really muslim and also i don't believe
in debt like personally like i think
debt is how a lot of people are
manipulated and
so um i like to listen to youtube videos
about
economics and and debt and money and the
only ones i could find in that world
were
islamic scholars because every other
economic system seems to be like oh this
is cheap debt expensive debt
bother all this and i'm like i wanted
advice from people that
don't want any debt like no mortgage no
debt and so i kept being drawn to
islamic scholars and then you see
through the lies
and um if you're being attacked that
hard by the muslim
by the media you're probably doing
something right so that's kind of my
my journey out of um you know
out of seeing muslims is is the enemy
and seeing like the spell for what it is
you know
we're going to jump into some of these
clips and get your guys reaction but you
mentioned 911 what do you think about
this one i know if you've ever heard
david ray griffin he said all the all
the evidence that america was attacked
this is a christian now professor
emeritus he said the evidence that all
the evidence that's presented that
america was attacked by muslims on 9 11
when subjected to critical scrutiny
appears to have been fabricated this is
a christian
who came out he wrote the most on this
so we have a new slogan
uh when it comes around never forget uh
we will never
islam and muslim had nothing to do with
9 11. i don't know if you know this is
the new slogan
good for you yeah and it and even if it
was 19 people
who call themselves muslim there's
nothing in the quran i've i've
asked a bunch of my friends about this
there's no commandment or anything it
has nothing to do with islam
and you can't label you can't put
a label on a billion plus people for the
actions of 19 like
no white christian american would want
that you know like the actions of a
small group of people
being perpetuated on to a demographic is
without question
a bad thing to do so i think after the
emotions of that
and then the truther movement of like
what happened to building seven and all
this stuff
you know i actually swung too far the
other way for a little while and i was
like
feeling victimized by like jews and
zionists and stuff and how like
they tricked me and dead and pornography
and all that
and then i realized that they're also
being used by
you know shaitaan it's like shaytan
so these guys are are are being used
in the system the same way like much
worse
actually and so the key is just to get
out of debt yourself
don't consume their media and then you
see them as a lot of people that are
just way off the path and and could use
a little love themselves you know
yeah well so you know about shaytan huh
oh yeah one of my best friends is muslim
and like
the interesting thing is it's uh a lot
one thing i appreciate about a lot of
muslims
is um i don't know if it maybe it's
because of your 21st century oppression
especially in the west but you're way
more connected to the
religion of it like like you you are
living it more like it's real versus a
lot of
american christians um are more detached
from it the rural ones are more
connected but a lot of the
big mega churches and stuff i'm like
you're not even reading it like it's
real
you know like i have all these questions
and i'm trying to connect to god and i'm
like
really taking this stuff seriously and a
lot of them are like
they act like it's not real and then you
have a lot of
muslims i know and a lot of uh you know
the amish the mennonites some of the
mormons i know like it's not just
muslims but it's like a lot of the
muslims i know are
in it more and i really respect that
about you guys because it's like
it's not just like a an intellectual
idea it's not a place to go on sundays
it's like a real way to live your life
and
you know that's why i'm trying to pick
up the plow and do my
uh work and really connect to nature and
to god as much as i can a lot of these
city people they
they don't seem like they have any
interest in it at all you know
much of that is going to appreciate what
you're saying regarding that thank you
let's
let's go into these clips this is the
inter the famous intervention
right which is one of the sacred
mysteries of the catholic faith and it's
a a a truth that is beyond human
comprehension
we can know that god exists through
reason but we couldn't know what he was
like
uh unless he told us and he told us
through the scriptures
uh basically with you by using two words
the two words are logos and son
and b and for 300 years the church
mulled over those two words and they
came up with the doctrine of the trinity
but since the trinity is the ultimate
reality
of the universe uh there's evidence of
the trinity
in nature and one of the people who
discovered this was pythagoras
probably the first one who discovered it
and discovered it in the realm
of number and number for pythagoras
one had meaning all the numbers had
meaning and the number one
uh meant unity and the number two
meant diversity and the number three
meant unity in diversity
if you take unity in diversity another
word for that
is beauty and beauty
is a transcendental which means it's an
attribute of god
and so you have an example of the uh
evidence of the trinity in nature itself
which kind of diffuses the whole issue
of uh accepting it completely on faith
alone
all right so what's going on here for
you guys i don't know owen benjamin here
is
on the right and then you have dr rachel
here
you have patrick coffin and dr michael
jones who were just speaking so we're
going to go through some of the videos
and there what they're doing uh help me
out um owen
is that they're trying to persuade you
or they're trying to do an intervention
because you're questioning some of these
things so we're going to look at some of
the arguments that they're making just
talk about it
uh dr sabil if give you a background
owen
he's actually a medical doctor by
profession he gave up uh
his medical career to go ahead and help
educate people
on islam to dedicate his life full time
he runs
a organization called gain peace he's
the director of game peace
and he's also here to answer any
questions that you have also
on islam because i remember you said
before you about bringing on an imam so
he's the closest thing
to that so he's someone who's also an
expert in comparative religion
he's dedicated a great portion of his
time
to the bible to understanding it and
to um helping you know create dialogue
and
these kind of talks um with people of
other faiths
so what do you think uh dr sabile you
want to comment on it or
owen who wants to go first on
go ahead i'd love to hear you yes yes so
brother i want you know
as soon as i saw that video you know i
didn't see that whole one hour
30 minutes right i mean i started to
watch it it was just too overwhelming
yeah yeah the way that they were
stopping you and ridiculing you i
thought
i mean i just didn't felt right yeah
they muted me so i just started going
like this and like
you are doing like this and you were
trying to say something he kept on
muting you
but regardless you know this person who
came up and he said you know catholic
they believe in trinity
mathematical equation and beauty in
nature
didn't you realize that he failed to
give a single evidence from the bible
yeah yeah totally and and i will say i
love you michael jones and all those
people like they are good people like
i'm not
mad at them at all but like that was
totally
i was the only one quoting the bible and
i couldn't stop laughing
another thing is i was the only one in
nature so he keeps talking about
nature and i'm like in nature like
surrounded by nature
and i'm like guys you wanna know about
all the numbers in nature there's fours
there's twos there's fives there's eight
there's nine wait till you get into some
of the fractals you know
and um i i get what they're saying and i
understand how there is a lot of threes
in nature you know where it's like um
father mother child you know we have all
kinds of you know um
ice water gas all that stuff but like i
i instinctively have a feeling like to
apply that
to god is is off and and i have a right
to think that way
and if people have a problem with that
that's their problem because i have not
distanced myself to
from people that believe that at all in
fact i got none beloved for them it
seemed like the reaction against me was
so disproportionate
where it's like they were almost more
mad at me for saying jesus wasn't
god like that statement uh
and and i was like he's in like uh doing
god's will
he's like connected he's like fully in
the will of god but it wasn't enough it
was like
that anger made me start as a comedian
you know you you can feel the stress
it's almost like being a masseuse like
uh there's a knot there and you're like
oh that's where i got a hit because it's
like
the overreaction where you can't do a
joke about
you know caitlyn bruce jenner or
whatever like when i saw that i'm like
that's where i got a joke or when it's
like you can't do jokes about
men and women anymore out of hollywood
like i'm like so that's where i got a
hit
and the same thing happened with trinity
where i was like
why are you calling me a heathen saying
i'm going to house and i'm not christian
all this stuff when like
jesus in the bible is talking about
praying to god and how we'll do more
than he ever did and how to help connect
us to
god the father and all this stuff and
i'm like i don't
see it in the bible and then people were
like john 3 16 and all this stuff and
i'm like
but there's so much that isn't that and
so and i'm not a theologian and i
i'm i don't it's like if i go too far
into that
or that's why i don't go into politics
either i can't do my job as a comedian
because i can't have sacred house
but like i felt it was my obligation as
somebody
that makes fun of stuff you know and the
joke that i i
i started doing was uh you know they'd
say 100
man 100 god and i'm like and so then i'm
like so can i pray to the holy ghost
like 100
ghosts 100 god and they're like no that
doesn't make any sense i'm like i know
right
i'm like it goes to god too then it's
like oh no the ghost isn't god i'm like
100 percent ghost 100
god you know and they're like no no it's
just the other way though i'm like
but if it's a trinity and all three are
one and all one or three then the ghost
is god
and they're like and a lot of people
laughed at that because our catholic
upbringing
really didn't explore the bible as much
as some of my other christian friends i
have now
rural christians that are more
biblically based
we'd all ask these questions and
everyone just told us to shut up
when we're kids and then we just never
went back to it and it just became part
of our identity you know
you know one one stark difference
between catholicism christianity
compared to islam
there are close to 700 passages in the
quran
that encourages and obligates people to
speak up
to think and ponder and ask questions
yeah
blindly believe just because our parents
and ancestors used to believe certain
way
that's what makes us different from
animals right we are different we are
saying
dude exactly yeah animals react i mean
animals are very beautiful
i'm with them right now as you can see
like the difference
is they're based in a world of reaction
there's a lot of love in animals i got
love for animals but it's
they don't have that other gear that i'm
not going to give up it's the same thing
with what's happening with a lot of the
global stuff you know we'll we don't
need to discuss it since i'd like to
test it out
but it's like but it's like to not be
able to question things
a i could not be a comedian at all you
know
i used to do bits about all the nonsense
so it's like someone just
someone invited me to go to uh to a skin
cancer walk in los
angeles and i was like outside you know
like little silly jokes like that where
it's like
you know what i mean where it's like oh
caitlyn jenner's woman of the year but
hasn't been a woman for a full year
isn't that mathematically impossible you
know like those little things are what
make
a comedian a comedian and those are also
a thing that make you
a living man you know um more more in
the
realm of of god's creation and not just
servitude and i think there's some real
nefarious powers to be
that want us a lot more like cattle than
like living men
and that is in a world of reaction where
the mass today take the mask off do this
don't do that you know
and i just won't do that because if you
give that up you give up
all the gifts you have you know yeah
here's the second here's the second one
dr rachel will
get you uh after this doctor's ability
i'd like to test it out with us
the problem of understanding the trinity
is the problem of understanding
how the maker of all things heaven and
earth
can enter into his own artwork right and
this is it's the way tolkien puts it in
one of his dialogues where he said the
elf and the woman are talking and she's
saying wouldn't it just break everything
to have the author of all things in fact
become part of
the story which is why it breaks our
brains to consider it right and and i
think i heard you saying
we don't understand how do you
conceptualize creation right how do you
understand
that the idea that we're all made we're
all creatures we're awesome
well one of my favorite authors is
dorothy sayers and she has
a wonderful book called the mind of the
maker where she talks through this
this metaphor of what it means to say
god is the
maker of heaven and earth and how in
fact the trinity is a metaphor that's
helping us understand what it means to
be artists
made in the image and likeness of god
which this is different from the
dr seville yeah yeah i mean again
you know not a single passage from the
old testament new testament any
scripture just philosophical just
philosophical
you know one of the marks of your true
faith is that it does not defy
our hearts our minds and the scriptures
because there's so many faiths out there
and you know we don't have to be a
theologian
to to demarcate you know which one is
the right and which one
can be the diluted versions of the
original so when we look at
you know the philosophical discussion
that she is mentioning
right away if i were there i would have
alluded her to the old testament and the
new testament and gave her two passages
one passage from the old testament is
the very first commandment
of the ten commandments in the book of
exodus chapter 20 verse number three god
says
do not take any other god besides me
right singular besides me
yeah it means no human no holy ghost no
animal no idol
can be equated with god that is the very
first the most important commandment
of the six hundred and thirteen
commandments of the old testament
when it comes to the new testament
brother owen you'll be so surprised to
find out
that one time a jewish person approached
jesus
and asked him a million dollar question
that of all the commandments of the old
testament
which one is the first the greatest of
all of them
this is in the gospel of mark the second
gospel chapter number 12 verse number 29
jesus he replied that hear o israel the
lord
our god his only one worship him he
didn't say worship me or
holy ghost worship him with all your
heart mind
soul and strength and that is the first
commandment
yeah in fact there's a passage in the
new testament i don't remember where
where
jesus uh actually stops someone from
giving him honor and says give it to god
and
it's those situations right where i'm
like how
is that make any sense if he's god like
someone was
giving him the honor giving him the
worship and he literally said no
he said don't do that give it to the
father and i'm this is in my christian
bible and i'm like
i don't see and and this is a cool thing
about islam and christianity there's one
reason why i think these lines are so
heavy in the sand
is because without the trinity islam and
christianity
shouldn't be enemies like they shouldn't
you know even with the trinity i
wouldn't
be an enemy of somebody that believes
something else than me but like
you're worshiping the same god you know
and so it's like
yeah my one my muslim friend has like
informed me that you guys have an
updated version he's like oh yeah
muhammad peace be upon him you know
but i'm like the broad strokes aren't
that
different it just isn't really anything
to be super fired up about you know
yeah there's a there's a passage the one
you're i think you're referring to
that's mark
10 18 where a man came to him and said
oh good master
what good thing can i do that i may have
eternal life i mean how do i get to
paradise he said
why do you call me good there's none
good but god that's just like someone i
always compared coming to me as a
martial artist and someone's just like
man eddie you could just kick somebody
you're so
you know and i'm just being humble you
know what i mean but jesus now he's like
supposed to be the creator of the
heavens and earth you know
no he's being humble he's saying look
you know he's saying god is the greatest
you know turn all your
love to god you know what i mean he's
keeping it humble and
directing that person and every all of
them to the one that he worshipped to
the creator of the heavens and
earth so in john chapter 5 verse number
30
jesus is mentioning to his people to the
disciples saying that i
of myself i cannot do anything whatever
i hear i judge
my judgment is true because i seek not
my own will
but the will of god who sent me it's so
important
cannot be as clear as that yeah and
that's why it's not even crit
it's not unchristian to question these
things when you read the new testament
that's why
people get so mad at me and i'm like i
don't i don't understand the anger
there's also and and even the parts that
the trinitarians are so obsessed about
like
i can't i think it might have been
philip but it was uh where it was like
basically how do i know god and jesus
basically said
uh you've been with me this whole time
have you not known god this whole you
know
i equate that to like being in the when
you're that committed to the will of god
you feel the presence around prophets
around
you know uh his his servants like if
somebody dedicates their life to god on
that level it's like
haven't you felt god when you're with me
like that i'm doing his will you know
and other people say like that means he
is god and i'm like
so did he make himself and then they say
uh
well in genesis in the beginning i think
there was a plural like we
or something there was like a a plural
uh verbiage
and you guys have any ideas about that
like in the beginning who is god with in
the in the plurality of that
yeah yeah in the in the book of genesis
chapter number one i believe verse
number 26 and on
16 and onwards how do you remember all
that bro
like that's crazy passages which are so
important of contention that you know we
just need to know them
that's amazing
brother owen it says in there that let
us make man
in our image right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the trinitarians they will look
at it and say you know there you go
there is a us there's a plural there's a
trinity
but those people who knows hebrew or
arabic
they know that in the semitic languages
they can be a royal v
a royal plural of authority interesting
yeah so this is how the languages are so
in the quran also it speaks
about v when god is only referring to
one person singular
so this is just the nature of the
language so about
people who don't know hebrew or aramaic
or arabic
they think this is a plural of trinity
no this is a plural of authority
for that reason not a single jewish
scholar in the history they took that as
trinity they took that as a plural of
authority
right we need to talk about the word of
god the written word of god has the
trinity
all over it even though we need an
external uh
authority to kind of draw that out and
synthesize it but it's a really funny
meme you'll like this
uh and it's my picture of how bad
catechesis has become
instruction the faith so it's it's our
lord in the garden of gethsemane
and he's like pleading against a rock
and he's saying
dad it's me you
yeah i wrote you you seen that
what so so the all i want to say is what
might help you
and i i'm not trying to convert you
because i can't but what might help is
okay so it's it's the distinction
between a nature and a person
see for 2000 years the church has taught
that god and the trinity are synonyms
god is a trinity even if he hadn't
created anything
he's still father and the son is always
being generated
in the eternal godhead what really
helped me from frank sheed's book was
that all analogies are really really uh
they're prone to limping badly when it
comes to the godhead because you can
always find some flaw in it and then
dismiss it
but um the distinction between nature
and person to me it was like light bulb
after light bulb going off
that god is one nature he's he's divine
he's uncreated he's all holy
and that is that that one divinity is
wholly possessed by three divine persons
so this is the third person this is uh
patrick huffington and all due respect
to all of them and
since you know them very well uh owen if
they'd like to come on we'd love to have
just you know a nice dialogue with them
maybe in the future you could set that
up
so uh doc sabil okay so this was the
last one they all had their chances to
speak and
tried to uh you know um intervene here
on
for owen regarding the trinity what do
you think about this argument um
dr seville the person the nature right
there are
three persons within one godhead jesus
never said that
none of the prophets of the old
testament ever define god like that see
god the concept of god is the
fundamental truth of any faith
that's the bedrock that's the foundation
of any faith it has to be clearly
defined
it cannot like it cannot be a mystery so
all the prophets of god
they clearly precisely in a clear-cut
way they all mention
there is only one god and he's the first
he is the last
he's the you know in the old testament
no less than two thousand places
like hundreds of places god says that i
am god
worship me not a single time jesus said
that i am god
or worship me right on top of it you
know brother you'll be so surprised to
find out
in the gospel of john the fourth gospel
chapter 17 verse number three
jesus pointing to the heavens he said
that this
is life eternal that you are the only
true god
and jesus sent by god so if there are
there is a category of god there is only
one person in that category
and that is the creator himself not
jesus
i love jesus go ahead finish that point
and then we're going to hear owen here
yeah yeah so so that's what i'm saying
right jesus himself
he mentioned that you are the only true
god that excludes him
and anyone else from being god
you know i love god i love jesus i the
whole insistence that
i understand jesus as the word of god
the living word i understand that
but the creator of the universe the
heaven and earth and and the other
dimension that allows for all that
i don't i just don't understand it and
i'd be lying if i did and from
my personal salvation comes from not
lying
so if i go along with something it's why
i got kicked out of hollywood because
i wouldn't go along with transgender
children i know that's why
michael jones got kicked out of a
catholic college because he wouldn't
sign off on
abortion which is one of the reasons
jones is one of my
uh favorite people because that's huge
you know and i'm sure a lot of people
there
said they understood the trilogy the
trinity but had no problem killing
unborn babies so
i judge people based on you know their
morality
and how much their uh as vox day says
the good the true and the beautiful
and right now i'm focused on making
communities local
um supply chains as the world collapses
because of uh you know graft and
disorder
and so if anyone wants to join bertare
times app
join that i'm going to pitch mine
all right i i want to i want a couple of
things that uh oh
owen said he mentioned uh obviously
believing loving jesus
we love jesus you cannot it's a tenant
of faith and this is not no like magic
spell nothing
there are six articles of faith and uh
to be a muslim
and one of us is to believe in the
messengers and jesus being one of the
five greatest messengers peace be upon
him
uh so you if you say that i don't
believe in jesus this can land you a
ticket to the hellfire
literally if you deny jesus in islam
remember islam
means to submit your will to the creator
of the heavens and earth and a muslim is
one
because we get caught up on these terms
and people think muslim arab in the
desert but a muslim is just simply
summarized with with uh in one word one
who submits his or her will to god to
the creator of the heavens and earth
so when he says that i believe he's the
word of god
what do you think when when he says that
dr sabil don't we believe that also
yeah well yes so in the quran also it
mentions that jesus is the word of god
but word of god is not like
god himself word of god is a command of
god
you know for that reason the quran says
you know when people when they equate
jesus
with god and vice versa and says that
god is the father
because he did not had a father god
himself gave an uh
gifts an argument in the quran in
chapter number 3
verse number 59 god says that the
likeness of jesus
in the eyes of god is similar to the
likeness of adam
he was made from dust and gods say be
and he was created
so the word of god is the command of god
it's not equal to god
so i think that's where christian
brothers and sisters they made a mistake
that when they say you know what when
the word became flesh no
the word is separate the word is the
command of the creator and by the
command of god
jesus and all of us and the whole
creation was created
so that's an important point that we
need to convey to them
yeah it's like uh and you get that when
you're on a homestead like the the old
joke what came first the chicken or the
egg
the answer is god you know like people
are always like what came first the
chicken or the egg it's like the chicken
well it came from an egg well where'd
the egg come from a chicken it came from
an egg it came from
it's like it has to come from the
creator that's why
um i agree with you on that because it's
like you can't
only god can create that spark
you know and there's no man rather
you're
doing the will of god or not that's ever
made a tree or a fish
right you know it just isn't is
impossible for a human being to do that
the human is is capable of making the
deceptions and the
the illusions and the spell craft oh and
i want to ask you something
one of my uh muslim friends
uh got me real and do uh black seeds
because i guess it's in the quran that
that's like the medicine for everything
and i wanna
since i have a doctor on here that's
also a muslim like what's uh because it
does work with a lot of stuff that that
black cumin seeds
what's what's that all about yes yes so
in the quran it mentions in chapter 33
verse number 21
that we should follow prophet muhammad
peace be upon him right his example his
role model
his life so one of the statements that
he made
he gave importance to the black seed oh
he also gave
gave importance to other fruits and you
know some other items
but especially to the yeah especially to
the black seed
so for that reason the scholars and the
you know the the modern day you know the
jurist
what they have done is you know along
with the other
treatment other medicine other advice
from the doctors let's also try the
prophetic wisdom
that he has mentioned uh in this
statement
that taking the black seed you know
eating it and mixing it in different
ways and
uh you know cooking it in different ways
so
that's where it comes from here we're
going to get into
another clip from owen here enjoy
trinity spouse because i don't care
either it's ego some things can't be
fully understood
no it's not because it can't be
understood it's a magic trick it's
three-card monty
we should start calling it trinity card
monty
it's a way for sinful people to not have
to address their sin
they're just always saved no matter what
they do that's the whole point
that's why they love that's why they're
so obsessed with it and i've been gate
capped by everybody you know it's like
we have an intervention you really
should be politically correct so we
don't look like cowards
we're gonna have an intervention you
really should say christianity is all
about the number three and not
living the bible you know
you're looking i'm looking at these like
city dwelling
beardless pale-faced
much-loved nonsense machines and they're
like oh we're gonna tell you about it
trinitarians don't read the bible to
read a million books about the bible
it's exactly dude
i was the only one mentioning the bible
and they're like well you know
jr you know tolkien said i'm like
and i don't even care the the the reason
i play played this clip here's
here's the takeaways i want to talk
about real quickly salvation because
uh owen made a brilliant point of people
being able to get away
you know from accountability of sins uh
he mentioned the beard i don't know if
you know oh and it's actually required
in islam to have a beard
you know it's one for men to grow beards
so
yeah it's so uh so and then uh yeah so
go ahead alexa weird you know it's
important that
i gave this lecture one time and the
discussion topic was
who is following jesus more are there
the muslims following him or the
christians following him
so i made like five different points
that they that we are the ones who are
following jesus
so the very moment that i gave is
obviously the beard right
because jesus and all the prophets they
had the beards and if you love jesus
be like jesus so we are we have the
beard because we want to be like him and
all the prophets
one right second when we fast in the
month of ramadan we are also following
the sunnah the example
of all the prophets including jesus
matthew 5
verse number 2 matthew 4 verse number 2
jesus used to fast the specific
you know number of days we are the ones
who are actually fasting that way
not just giving up one item or one thing
that we like
total absent is fasting the way all the
profits jesus used to fast that way
number three is when we meet each other
uh brother
what do we say do you know
yeah assalamu alaikum peace be upon you
lo and behold you'll be surprised to
find out
the book of john the gospel of john
chapter number 20 verse number 19.
jesus when he went to the upper chamber
he met his disciples and the very first
thing he mentioned to them was
peace be upon you number three
jesus was circumcised all the prophets
were circumcised
muslim meals we are circumcised but the
biggest thing that we are following
about jesus
is he was an absolute monotheistic
person
he never believed in trinity he never
preached unity
and monetism was the main belief or the
only foundational belief
that he shared with his people so if you
look at anyone in the whole world who is
actually practicing and following
prophet jesus right minutely we are the
ones muslims you know i mean if you can
add more things
he never ate pork in the old testament
it forbids pork
leviticus chapter 11 verse number three
and onwards
muslims we never ate pork we forbid pork
right the quran also forbids eating porn
so we can give many many examples saying
that yes muslims are minutely following
jesus and all the prophets of god
including the last one prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
and porn too it's like uh and like when
i've done stand up in the middle
east um there's a there's a real
opposition of pornography and in matthew
jesus said basically if you look at uh
a woman in lust you should stab your own
eye out which is
you know pretty intense and i think a
lot of people have gotten
way too accidental with those those
lustful tendencies
and uh i actually think it's the biggest
plague on the west right now is
pornography i think it's like the opium
war of the 21st century where
i think it's rewiring men's brains into
being these like
outside observers and very weak and very
passive and almost effeminate and very
permissive of like
child abuse and all this stuff and so
that's another part
that i think a lot of modern christians
and and i'm not saying all crit because
a lot of christians get it i know a lot
of christians that
really do follow the bible but the
modern popcorn christian like the the
mega churches the rainbow flag
christians like
you know those guys are not even close
like not even like
muslims are more christian than them
like by far
not even a comparison and that's why
when they condemn muslims for being this
like problem i'm like dude
they're actually living the bible way
more than you
you know because the fundamentals are
you know uh commandment one
is so important and so is like the
discipline required to to be in that
frequency of not being like completely
fallen and disgusting
you know to see like like lesbian female
preachers like
you're just like dude you're so far off
like seeing priests and pride parades
and
i'm like it's a pride parade what's up
next the wrath parade
you know and i think unfortunately that
may be coming at some point
i'm like you're not supposed to be
identified by your sins that means you
can't
we all sin and we all have problems but
it's like to be identified by that
is it means you've already taken the
ticket but they just keep saying like
i've accepted jesus christ so i'm saved
and i'm like
no he didn't like if you he didn't say
that you could just live any way you
want you don't just say magic words
in fact i bet in modern day
if they met jesus they'd probably hate
him or not want to be around him or
want him to get kicked off twitter you
know yeah
you know when you when you speak about
initially i think maybe 20 minutes ago
jesus was praying right and who was he
praying to
a question which i always ask to my
christian friends is
suppose if you see jesus praying would
you pray to him
or would you stand next to him to pray
to the same creator that he's praying to
it's a pray waterfall just pray to pray
to pray
that's just yeah direct worship right
so in islam there is no mediator because
god allah is all-knowing his all-hearing
why do we need to go through many many
channels when we can approach him
directly we have direct access to him
pray to him ask from him get the mercy
and the blessings from him
cool man uh i wanted to um before we get
into this next clip i want to get your
reaction to it
uh owen are there any questions that you
have
about islam i've just been really into
the history of it lately like i uh
like about like what happened in the
14th century with the fall of the
islamic empire and how that happened
like how
you know there's some some quotes that
my friend was telling me about how the
the horse archers came out
of china or mongolia or whatever and
they'd gotten so wealthy that they
didn't have an army or whatever
and i just like want to know like what's
the uh what's the uh
the history in your communities and in
your circles of what happened in
baghdad in those areas in the 14th
century because like you know especially
what's happening right now in america
i'm always curious of what the forces
are
uh in in empire and in conquest and all
that stuff and
and uh islamic empire so fascinating and
so
under taught in western schools that any
information about that would be awesome
yeah you know there is a good history
book that i can refer to you
uh maybe i can send it to eddie the name
of it and maybe you can purchase and you
can inshallah god building you can get
access to it
uh it is written by a good friend of
mine a local imam in chicago half is a
class
um brother eddie i will send the link so
you can pass it properly
you know one important topic then
brother eddie you can take over is
the the word christian you know they
were repeating it you are repeating it
it's important for me and you to know
historically
jesus never said that you know my
followers are christians
he never said that you are now named as
christians
in fact in all of the four gospels the
word christian does not occur at
all who do you think brother oh one
who coined the word christian for the
christians
probably the romans i think you are
right because what happened was
followers of christ they were going to
this idol worshippers
they were going to the city of antioch
to preach
the oneness of god over there the idol
worshippers they looked from inside the
city
the followers of christ are coming and
they said the idol worshippers
here comes the christians so they were
the ones who coined the word christians
to the followers of christ
not god not jesus not even paul none of
the disciples
but the idol worshippers and and you can
look this up
uh this is in the book of acts the fifth
book
chapter 11 verse number 26. on top of it
the word christianity
does not occur anywhere in the whole
bible
the word judaism does not occur in the
whole bible
the word trinity does not occur in the
whole bible
the word bible does not occur anywhere
in the bible
yeah there's spells you know like my my
dad's a rhetoric professor so
i i kind of from a young age i knew
about how spellcraft works and
and sometimes i i catch some of these
and i'm like
dude i'm starting to think that the
devil's like kind of like a really
really sick comedian where he's always
trying to
to humiliate man with like weird titles
and like tricks where it's like
banks that don't save money hospitals
don't heal schools to tell lies like
there's this weird inversion irony where
and i i kind of had that that idea
already that christian
was given by the romans is almost like a
mockery
but i that stuff doesn't bother me too
much because it's been 1700 years or
whatever and it's just like
it's just more of my cultural heritage
and like what i
you know it i don't know i can't explain
it but i do know that you're right
well i i assume you're right about that
because yeah i've done a lot of deep
dives into the bible with certain words
and
there was no bible jesus didn't even
write it dot like he there was no
bible no trinity no word christian they
were called holy
people who followed jesus were more
called holy and i think that comes from
the word whole
like total yeah they're called the
people of the way
people of the past that's that's awesome
yes and
they used to submit to god and anyone
who submits only to the one creator
and do the guidance and fulfills the
guidance that allah god has given
the term that we give that person is a
submitter to the creator
in arabic that person is called as a
muslim
so for that reason we say jesus was a
muslim because he used to submit to the
creator his followers were muslims
initial followers obviously all the
prophets were muslims
so the faith of islam is you know you
may be thinking
brother that it is a seventh century
faith founded by muhammad peace be upon
him
that's not the case though islam as a
guidance was given to the very first
human adam
and all the prophets they were given
that same faith of islam that means
only submit to the one creator follow
his guidance
and guard by his mercy will put you into
paradise
so what happened it's an eternal thing i
get it
it's like because the the truth is
fractal and everything in the world
that's why it's like
you don't need as as uh patrick coffin
was saying which i disagree with in that
intervention
um you don't need an outside authority
when he said it required the trinity
required an outside
authority an outside interpreter a
middleman you know it's like
the middleman the merchant you know it's
like i get it the the
the debt guy it's like you don't need
that it's like you can see
the truth in it in your life every day
like every commandment
every um element of it is is real
all around you all the time and has
always been here
like the truth one of the reasons people
say i'm a time traveler
i'm not by the way is because the truth
never changes so it appears i keep
seeing stuff coming
you know in my live streams and it's
because the truth doesn't change
you know the spells change the snake
eats itself all the nonsense all around
you but like
the truth is all is static it's still
it's loving you know it's it's like
and that's why i love how you guys
describe um
god as like being very forgiving and
very you know like
all powerful and without limits and very
merciful because
you know the fact that i have three
beautiful children and a wife and a farm
and all this stuff given what my life
has been like
i feel like god has given me tremendous
mercy and i am very happy for that i
think a lot of
people muslim or christian or whatever
people want to call themselves it's like
gratitude is so important here's another
thing i like about a lot of muslim
videos is you guys seem to
be able to identify the false virtue guy
at the mosque really well
because i think mohammed peace be upon
him
uh really hated now i'm not gonna use
the word hate but really didn't like the
guys that uh
that like uh pretended you know they
wanted virtue from their public like
their virtue
and their deeds but no real heart in it
you know and i think that
is a struggle that is eternal as well
and it can infest any community where
like
you're not doing it for the love of god
you're doing it for the lollipops and
fancy pants is what we like to call it
and um and you know i'm just i think
gratitude and
love and and uh truth is so important
and discipline
and uh it's really awesome that you gave
up being a doctor to uh
to spread islam because that's that's
cool man that's like really i know that
can be really hard for people to give up
uh
worldly status and uh you know the the
pit and the pedestal is very real
uh uh technique to keep people in
bondage and
it's really cool you did that yeah i
mean you know we only have one life to
live
once we are on in you know facing the
creator on the day of judgement and he's
asking us how did you live your life
i don't have a chance again to come back
to this world and do the things that i
want to do
to please him this is the only life just
do the best
you know learn the scriptures the quran
the final scripture
you know be like prophet muhammad peace
be upon him and all the wonderful
prophets help out humanity
only one life to live so have you felt
like your wife's gotten better though
like
like like when you really submit and you
really start doing what's right and not
just reliable like don't you feel better
now
i feel a lot better than before yes yes
you have the
content now we are trust god oh yeah
now we are more hopeful now we are away
from any depression
you know any medicine i mean i don't
take medicine but
you don't need any medicine at all now
god is the one who is going to be there
for you right so the ultimate trust the
piece of content
is just priceless we'll get this
reaction we got about 10 minutes left
we'll get uh a quick reaction from owen
we'll listen to this
uh i just want you to see just listen
and then owen just tell me
it's not a spell all right i just want
you to listen
and see yeah yeah
so just listen and see you know at the
end
like your reaction to it and then we'll
get into the final clip
about some farming farming and we'll
close it close it off
uh and then what i wanted to add to what
you guys were saying before before i
play this next clip is
uh what came to my mind is how simple
and profound
it is that you know if someone is
sincerely seeking
the pleasure of their creator to be
guided you know it's not convoluted like
the devil
tries to make it out to be it's just
someone within themselves
asking say the one who created me guide
me guide me guide me
you know just praying to the creator the
most loving the most merciful
and saying guide me what way do you want
me there's so much out there which is
the correct way
guide me that's it how many people
actually ask for guidance directly
to the creator that has the nerve so
that that's i think the formula and be
grateful grateful and thankful yes
the reaction to this
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it was great man i love that so
this is do you know what that was
i don't thi this was go ahead dr bill
what was he listening to yeah obviously
this is a recitation from the quran
the last testament that god has given as
a guidance to humanity
and it basically referring uh about the
grand reality
means which is the clear manifestation
the clear uh which is the clear
reality that we all know and we all have
to face
that there is only one creator all the
prophets they came
to speak about him to invite people to
worship him
and if we do our best if there is any
shortcoming obviously we should repent
to the creator directly no mediator
and it says in the quran he will forgive
all the sins you know except one sin if
a person dies with that
the sin of associating partners with god
saying that this person is god or that
idol is god or this
this part of the creation is god but
generally any other sin
allah god can forgive so our reality is
that
god has given us guidance and by obeying
the guidance
inshallah god willing by his mercy we
will go to paradise
so that is the grand reality and there
is a message that god has sent
to all the prophets and the messengers
so we can always discuss so many topics
about trinity
the concept of god right the scriptures
the way for salvation
at the end of the day me you every
single one of us
we have to face the creator you know
just like when we went to schools and
colleges
there is a assessment at the end of the
semester
by the teacher based upon all the things
that we have done that semester
so the final grade of ours as humans as
individuals
would be given to us on the day of
judgement so ultimately there would be
two options up there right or the two
only two places
that god can put us either in paradise
we hope and pray all of us
or hell fire and we seek allah's god you
know god's protection against it
so so according to the islamic theology
to go to paradise would be
we don't worship anyone else besides one
god
we believe in all the prophets and the
messengers and all the scriptures given
before
the quran came and now the final
scripture because the previous
scriptures
the old testament the new testament they
were all have been edited
and revised and altered we don't have
them in
in the pure way that they were given to
the previous prophets
and then we believe in the angels and in
the divine decree
and on the day of judgment so once a
person believes in this grand reality
and do the deeds that god wants us to do
that's
the way for salvation according to islam
you are saying something brotherhood
oh yeah is there uh periods of hellfire
do you guys believe that
that you might have to burn for a little
while and then you can get out
so generally both hellfire and paradise
there forever
like paradise forever for sure right but
most believers
whose sins are not forgiven they would
be purified
in the hellfire for whatever length of
time and then they would be taken out
but those individuals for example
despite knowing the truth
they keep on associating partners keep
on believing and worshiping a creation
along with god or instead of god you
know according to the quran it will be
there for a long time
yeah yeah because that's that's that's
how that's what my instincts tell me
is like uh because i i think that
there's like fractal realities of that
while you're alive like the more you go
against god
it may appear that you're doing well but
you're not allowed to feel joy
and like you start like burning almost
where it's like
does that make sense it's almost like a
correction where it's like you got to
get back on the path
and if you refuse and if you're stubborn
and if you don't accept
that burning like and this is even while
you're alive and i'm sure after
it's like way crazier but like that's
that's kind of like what my instincts
say we're like
you know there's there's correction
mechanisms where if somebody
sees sees it they can be purged of sin
versus just like maybe there's some
people that are just you know gonna burn
forever
that just sounds so horrifying now
you know for that reason we say that
this life is a testing ground
yeah yeah yeah true god has given us
clear guidance
he he gave us clear guidance and he has
also showed us you know what is the
error
that we should be uh staying away from
so on the day of judgement we cannot
blame satan you know shaytan
right shaytan is going to say on the day
of judgement i just told you to do this
you are the one who actually did it you
mean you know anyone i'm saying
you are the one who actually did it so
he's going to you know walk away
we cannot you know hold him and say you
know what god he's the one who took us
here no ultimately we are the ones god
gave us the ability the thinking the
conscious
that we should be the one making the
right decisions and not blame on anyone
else
yeah it's still true man it's like that
when you're getting a loan you know it's
like when they repossess your house
you can say i didn't know but they're
like
you read the contract i gave you a
contract it's that adjustable rate
mortgage
like you agreed and that's why i think a
lot of the
people on this earth who are doing the
bidding of
shaitaan uh get away with it because
they require you to know and to contract
with them
and then they get to walk away and i
think that happens as well
with judgment where it's like you can
never say the devil made you do it you
know
exactly exactly you know many of my
so so far we have about 5 000 plus
people
on behalf of the organization that i'm
director of
they of their own choice in a majority
of them they are from the christian
background
once they started to read the quran they
found the answers in the quran to the
questions they had all throughout their
lives
you know who is the creator is he one in
one or is he one in three
they found the answer in the quran with
clarity about who jesus
is you know jesus is the son of god he
is also god and god came down
god died who is going to run the
universe this confusion quran gives the
clear-cut
answer that satisfies here and here what
guidance to follow we all need to follow
some guidance
when we went to school when we drive on
the road right when we go to any work
there is some do's and don'ts we are
supposed to follow so what kind of
guidance that god has given us to follow
both individuals
and his family and his humanity so
in the quran it's a comprehensive
guidance so again over there
a person gets you know connected with it
and lastly how to go to paradise is it
somebody dying for us
is it reincarnation after reincarnation
the cycle goes on and on
or is it personal accountability that
you drive over the limit you get the
ticket not you or not anyone else
right so all of these four important
concepts brother owen
they appeal to these individuals so that
is the reason islam is the fastest
growing faith in the usa
and actually around the world so my
sincere hope and uh you know my
encouragement to you
is you know read the quran i'm not sure
if you have a copy of the quran
do you i have one i've read about it's
the one i have is really uh
really intense it has like footnotes of
every line and like all
and so it was a little heavy but my
friend said he might
he has a simpler version um yeah so i'll
check it out but he sends me uh
like memes and cool videos and stuff all
the time so i'm i'm really glad you guys
exist man i think you guys are uh uh
really cool people
yeah and uh go ahead go ahead sorry
you're finishing
well no i just it's just really cool
because that's what i i don't understand
about
i guess i do understand but some people
don't want to let go
hatred that they know is fake now
because i'm
i'm considered a truther you know where
it's like i like to get to the bottom of
stuff even if it costs me
you know social status but and then like
so
we get to the bottom of 911 not who did
it that's too hard to do
but like building seven fall i i you
know i don't want to get your youtube
channel flag or anything so
we all know that there's nonsense but
yet people will still hold on to
the hate to justify empire wars and i'm
like
why won't you let that go now like we're
past that
how do you not now know that there's no
muslim burial 80
miles off the coast of like on a ship
like looking back
we were so tricked like they said osama
bin laden
had a muslim burial an anonymous 80
miles
off the coast they dropped him off a
boat
and like all the right wingers were all
up in arms like how dare
obama give him a muslim burial and and
the other people were like he deserves a
muslim berry i'm like
how is that a muslim burial like is that
a muslim burial guys do you get dropped
off a ship 80 miles off the coast like i
i think that sounds and so what i hope
for the future is that people once
people see
that someone isn't your enemy or that a
lot of people like the way muslims live
i think is really beautiful
i think that um that submission to god
that that's what that means that's
awesome
that it's like you you don't like debt
you don't like pornography you follow
the prophets you follow god i think
that's just so great man it's like
um i think i really hope that more
people see that
and they don't hold on to that because
it'll only hurt them in the long run
where they they're holding on to like
lies because it'll justify their sin
like i'm tight with a lot of special
forces guys and stuff like that
and a lot of them the only way they got
through the wars
is admitting that they were guarding a
poppy field like admit it like we
weren't there avenging
new york city you know it's been 20
years and
once they admit that and the truth sets
them free then they're good again and
that's how
i believe that god is merciful because
like people have done some crazy stuff
under these spells myself included i'm
sure i'm under a spell right now that
i'm not aware of
but like to to admit it when you see it
is so important and that's why
i'm really glad that we're all friends
and we can have these conversations
because like
i'm not gonna pretend something is
something it isn't
you know and i hope more people see that
about islam and how
how close it is to the christian bible
and how it isn't
you know it's the christian dogma that
got so crazy specifically rome in my
opinion
and it's like i just hope people really
focus on
the upcoming problems we have which are
all familial you know it's all about
keeping that family together one thing i
love about islam is uh
that you guys talk about how um
it's like uh if if if a little demon
gets a
husband and wife to fight he gets to sit
on like satan's lap or something
is that like in a hadith or something
yeah yeah so so that's what
shaitaan uh you know he wants to split
the communities he wants to speak the
families right
yes he does and so you guys are so
family oriented that i love that because
that shaitan wants the mom and dad to
split they want
the communities to split they want the
wells to go dry
no more cow like none of this satan does
not like that
satan is not like like i can supply milk
for five families and that like
me and my friends can all get together
and do our own things
satan wants the atomization so i i dig
what you guys are doing and i'm glad we
had this conversation
that's uh interesting you brought up
this uh authentic hadith
because this hadith illustrates the
importance of family like
how the devil you know the shaitan this
is the chief
you know the chief deceiver iblees the
the head devil
and then you have all the the the other
satanic forces so he's sitting and he's
calling them and he's saying
okay what did you do today for instance
this one said i had this one commit
fornication
okay yeah and then he said this one what
did you do i had this one steal okay
these are evil things they're evil right
but he's like okay no big deal right
okay then he says what did you do
i split a husband from his wife he said
ah
boom come over here come to me here he
put he put the crown on his head because
what happens if you break the home
you break the society right all these
other things are evil but that's the key
one so that's what's important in islam
is to hold the family unity
because you hold the family unity that's
what makes a society
right let me get into this last one you
have a uh you have
someone who really likes uh who follows
you he's from uh bosnia so you even your
your work is reaching
all the way to bosnia oh and and i i
think i i just give you a quick summary
uh you had the back where my roots back
in boston
i was born in the united states but my
family comes from bosnia this is in the
heart of europe
and quick summary you had unitarian
christians there
you know who when islam came these were
unitarian christians who didn't believe
in the trinity
you know similar to to you and many
others uh they would not
they would pray outside they would pray
like jesus prayed
to the creator the heavens and earth and
when submission to the will of the
creator came
to islam well that's what it means to
submit your will to god
they were the largest concentrated group
of people who accepted islam all at once
so this is in the heart there
in baz in europe bosnia so
we're here at the farm and if you ever i
think i mentioned this to you before
uh orhan would love to host you so this
is me there you can kind of give you
just
a little bit of what uh you would you
would see and where you'd stay
nice
it's the milking station here beautiful
that's the big man wow
a lot of milk beautiful
the almighty set it up where they start
what happens they start to grow
eat more and grow more more specific
specific hair
mine is 25 degrees
these are the females now look at the
male here what do you
see if you could strike the the
difference
here's your favorite so this is the male
huh
look he's got a beard he's got a beard
that is awesome wow look at that place
beautiful what's in here actually
this is not alcohol these are all juices
made from
marshmallow corn here or more gmo
really this is beautiful so this is life
in the united states
yes in the united states the corn is uh
80
or more gmo this is non-gmo corn
this is the real corn here so you'd be
eating organic real
purely organic real corn
well that's the life
[Music]
and then we get you some horse riding
i don't know if there's one for my side
i'm six eight man i'm a giant
we got the big horses too so this is uh
we're we're i'm sure
odan would love to host you there yeah
man if
next tour if i come through i'm
definitely coming so if you're ever
in europe uh get to see this and i'll
hook you up he'd love to uh
to have you there in uh in bosnia and
sarajevo
let's get you out we'll get you to the
farm all right closing comments uh dr
sebia owen we're
we're coming to a close here i think
this is a
blast man no go ahead doctor you know
what
i mean i want to really appreciate you
know the sincerity that you have
being brought up in the culture here
with so much pressure
to retain you know what you have been
given it just me it just makes a person
you know
with that much sincerity to look out and
to question
and to seek for the truth so i really uh
you know really appreciate what you're
saying what you're doing
you know if people don't know your
background just looking at three of us
they will say you know what these three
muslim guys are in the show
they will take you as a muslim based
upon the comments that you have
you know the concept of god that you're
saying
and all the wonderful things so i would
really suggest to your brother
that you know read the quran read it
again
ask questions me and eddie we are always
here to help you
and inshallah god willing you will find
that it will give you peace and content
and it will connect with the bigger
reality that means there is only one
creator
knowing him following him knowing his
guidance following the guidance
and praying to god for giving us the
content the peace the solutions in this
life
so i think that is the bigger reality
that you know i would
really hope and pray that you will
do more research and i pray to god that
may god guide you may god bless you and
your family
so you and your family can get eternal
paradise and all of us
are mean you as well my friend that's
beautiful man
and i'd just like to also tell your
audience that um um
my comedy is uh there's vulgarity in it
and so but it's in a world of vulgarity
and so
it's not for kids so if anybody wants to
look me up and check it out
it isn't evil though it isn't bad it's
like
it's a language that is part of the
culture i was trying to dismantle like
the the really sick culture that's kind
of developed in the west
sometimes you have to have the uh the
language of that which you're
mocking so i just want to give a
disclaimer for that because you can
check out my
specials at unauthorized tv or amazon
prime or comedy central or any of that
stuff
and uh but for the family for the that
that beautiful bosnian family i just saw
we have developed a uh
more of a solutions oriented thing like
more of a
uh the beretaria times app it's
completely clean it's like
a five-year-old can scroll through it
it's all solutions based it's not about
complaining
it's about like growing starting
families
you know connecting homesteads and
because i'm not
in the the complaint business these days
it's like
enough people are seeing the system and
how it's victimizing a lot of people
and so me and some friends figured out a
a way to help each other
connect and to uh and to grow so i just
want to let your audience know that that
when they check out my comedy
the adults will get it uh but there is
vulgarity to it
and i out of respect i'm being very
obviously uh
non-vulgar in this conversation but so
just keep just watch out for that
but at the same time uh you'll see the
points i'm making and how it isn't
i'm never encouraging the sin it's i'm
mocking this in but
it's it's like i'm doing it in a way
that uh that people will listen to
thank you owen really nice to have you
on the program again if you're also in
chicago or by indiana sometime northwest
uh hit me up and hopefully we can all
meet up
in person someday i will that'd be great
and if you're ever in idaho
you're always welcome god bless you man
thank you
anyone else would like to get a free
copy and also my organization what we do
is
we mail out free copies of the quran
anywhere in the usa
for people to read it and educate
themselves do away with the
misconceptions and inshallah hopefully
find guidance
they can go to the website gamepeace.com
and awesome yeah so anyone yourself your
family your friends they can get a free
copy
of the muslim community thank you paul
god bless you both thank you
thank you peace